I thought we were gonna start at 11 I
know it's at 11:30 you know who is the
last guy to be late and I just turned
him turn him away tige but wait a minute
before you before you sidetrack me okay
the end result of tiga
was what he didn't come he wanted to
reschedule for a later time I stone we
can do you shut it down fired yeah it
doesn't work like that and then you're
like and if you want if you got problems
like I'm body-slamming [ __ ]
like did you say that in the text like
I'll say I'm like I'm not with all that
other blah just talking it's not gonna
work out just forget about it bah bah
and he's like no I can come on like no
it's good then his publicist she's like
I realistic come on by and they're like
make excuses for him I was just like
stop stop she's like this young
publicist from MTV trying to get his
show to get viewers I just say just stop
it's all good
just that was it that's we took a lot of
heat for it and like açaí he didn't come
you took a lot of heat because he didn't
show we took a lot of heat because we're
gonna allow him on the show oh I like
upset that you know what you're selling
out or some key let me tell you since
selling out there like or what what
would tea good itching to talk about
like listen I would you like is me music
or not I don't know his music I just
know I I gotta say I think he's got
probably one of the illest [ __ ] Styles
out there because from what I heard from
what I heard his girl intimacy his girl
entomb two million dollars now that's
that's a [ __ ] game right there the [ __ ]
game no no that's a [ __ ] but I can't get
5 bucks we neither here's the [ __ ] man a
girl let me $20 it's the flushing no no
he was 23 or 24 when he was dating is it
Kylie Kylie she was 16 my man yeah he's
one thing the younger girls while and
then his baby mama is many I know he
girls brought these wild so I'll talk
about a [ __ ] stop yeah he's got an ill
[ __ ] stop so can we call Cowan at some
point and tell him like y'all half a rat
set your on set what the [ __ ] he's not
making Apocalypse Now I might say he's
doing a [ __ ] Goldbergs get the [ __ ]
out of here can we can we try him he's
all set you [ __ ] [ __ ] yours I wish
ma'am yeah [ __ ] out of here he's on set
you know what the set of the Goldbergs
is like it's [ __ ] easy it's easy
money over
I'm on sick making the [ __ ] Godfather
I'm on sick get it no [ __ ] he told you
he's on say I come down with so much I
wish someone said oh I'm studying I'm in
carries getting in character as a clown
eating [ __ ] man but if this isn't the
biggest fight in UFC history it's gonna
show you whether you have the stay the
UFC's that in terms of what of power and
with the cell with the Reebok deal I
think
UFC 200 was kind of the first black guy
whichever right what the [ __ ] was this Y
is the octagon yellow and why is Brock
Lesnar on steroids like there's all you
know I'm like these fights [ __ ]
sucked
that was the first one where I was like
mm not great but Connors your saving
grace right if cuz you look at Connors
numbers right through three major papers
and it's international to Rouen they're
grown right and then if this one
especially Diaz we're gonna watch this
[ __ ] if this is done set a record and
let you know you'll season a little bit
trouble the guys you bother going [ __ ]
so what I got so many questions running
yet hold on so the guys who bought it
let's get to them and the 4.2 billion
dollars but who what if he what is the
other fight on this card Saturday then
I'm gonna spend what 59.99 H dearly a 69
[ __ ] may need it in HD yeah you
got so at least yo my man Evan Evan yo
yo well can I at least get $69.99 don't
have to [ __ ] waste our money if
things go right now I got you dawg what
the [ __ ] bring the squad over man I'll
get chicken wings you sure maybe just
get Evan I'm asking you can I get the
sixty nine ninety like what the free new
bill Evan for $70 okay okay they're
counting since he's [ __ ] doing the
gold but how knows you $70 yeah
[ __ ] but then you need wings and
couple drinks so what's the other
highlight fight of this night there's
that well glow vertex your verse Anthony
Johnson right [ __ ] bang are they
gonna bang Peppa Peppa hangar the
fastest mile ever ran I ran a sub
six-minute mile okay I'm trying at 245
pounds
but at 7:00 now except tomorrow's a
class night probably let's say an eight
mile a minute mile easy flirting guys
are running like the whole thing is 27
minutes I'll know they're [ __ ] right
hey bro will you compare me to these
funds in that's what they do but you're
say so you're you're you did seven miles
the other day that was just your whole
workout yes and where do you do this on
that [ __ ] smells did on the boardwalk
from Venice pier to Santa Monica Pier
okay and you don't stop no like you
don't tweet and like hey guys what's
going on yeah but show you ready guys
mile forest getting hollow right here
how's my hair look so but when you do
the seven miles are you are you like
what is your pace is it like a pace are
you like is it like cuz I just want you
to like I am one of the slowest people
but you run long distance [ __ ] no no I
don't run long this is I don't run short
distance I'm just saying I'm fasting
like seven miles to me is that's like
the most I've ever done in my life is
five and that was like in the 90s but it
but if you did it and you got you stood
it'd be a different story you've never
seen me run but you played basketball so
there's so many London 90s you play that
I've seen those celebrity game but said
you'd be up like [ __ ] Bieber's
separate cheese mess around you're dead
serious yeah no I'm not dead serious no
your dad you're dying like Bieber but I
Bieber's got nothing for me when we play
ball like what if he goes all out and I
go all out and I'll say that I could be
on my [ __ ] deathbed the diabetes and
like a clubfoot and I always build a
beat Justin Bieber in basketball and he
knows that and I know that an article
from The Washington Post that went up
detailing a research study that proved
that today's men are significant have
significantly weaker grip strength it is
strength in general than our basically
our dads where do they come up with this
[ __ ] from you know how they do it they
manual labor cause Oh cuz I could see
that that's what they're saying like now
kids like when they grow up this
electronic I think that your labor and
usually they test strength by there's a
device with grips do you strong grip I
do I'm
my thing what do you mean well why do
you want me to squeeze your hand like if
I think I got a good position no you
can't do it's not thick knuckles no but
it's also I got the position you know
how because I you know okay let go ah
[ __ ] let's do left I'm lefting okay
let's do look this is gonna be a
standoff this is a student think you
might get me an endurance turning red
okay you [ __ ] okay
god damn you [ __ ] animal you through
this I'm known for my Bach man's but is
if I was an x-men that'd be my super
balance ah [ __ ] I had for a minute you
did have a [ __ ] you man good for you I
didn't want to do this 9 then they sting
me man
sorry bro [ __ ] guessed it I'll
[ __ ] jealous your idea Oh Bryan
Callen oh hey man listen to me you [ __ ]
the shows it's over for you [ __ ] it's
now called Rappaport dot and the kid
you're done yeah you're not doing
Shakespeare you little prick okay you're
not doing the Godfather you're not doing
[ __ ] Romeo and Juliet you're doing an
episode of the Goldberg your own set so
we we we've negotiated over here that
this is worth $200 like a number one I
shouldn't have to pay for the fight on
Sunday Saturday and then like just like
parking gas and all it's all I need two
hundred dollars sent in a money order
you little prick
yeah this is my [ __ ] career listen to
me listen to me you little [ __ ] DUI I
saw you [ __ ]
listen to me you little prick you shaved
that perpetual five o'clock shadow
finally huh
are you nude right now are you and your
are you and your trailer cuz we're not
on right now cuz I finished shooting no
cuz it was cool doing it with Brendan
but you know sometimes I think like
sometimes I'm looks like Brendan shut
the [ __ ] up aren't you sometimes like
Brendan shut the [ __ ] up and I loved the
UFC
Dana might have his opinions on me I
don't give a [ __ ] I keep doing my thing
he laughs he seems to work out they can
use whatever they want it's an honor man
III don't want money from it I'm not
strapped for cash I don't give a [ __ ]
it helps me out I'm honored to be a part
of that guy that's dope man right I
don't care I agree I agree III don't
agree with necessary those jeans you're
wearing you want to show the people
about those I'm where I came in shorts
cuz wrong I came in shorts see I was
gonna be she was gonna be cool just you
eat him only Kyle I get away a little
dressing like that why you wearing
shorts because it's [ __ ] 170 degrees
out you don't wear shorts please stand
volts people a style you like what's
wrapped up no no please stand no let him
see the jeans these are my motorcycle
jeans no where's the motorcycle my man
we're doing this is pocket broadcasting
gene bro you have you have plaid shorts
on with these widest legs I've ever seen
then you have black socks
you're not at the beach you're nowhere
near the beach if I wash some dishes I
could relic what is this ability you me
you giving me style advice like Ray
Charles mad bro check me me me me got me
up meet me amigo me me me God let me
explain something to you give me style
advices like Lindsay Lohan really that's
your last meet me amigo let me go the
mix myself you give me start by this is
like Adele being like you shouldn't eat
then my friend my friend
you give me style advices like Donald
Trump saying I think she called you got
this one Kurt Cobain shirt with the N
Sync jeans you know what guys were a
couple of clean faced [ __ ] we
are sad and cut my man hey man what come
over this weekend for a party why not
man yeah get some grown man [ __ ] to do
it doesn't involve getting wasted and
smoking weed every night yeah just
doesn't yep yeah
that that's that that is that weird sort
of thing that you see in a society that
especially a culture like la that
essentially is about get like people
come here from somewhere else a lot of
times they didn't like where they came
from so they reinvent themselves they
got a story they attach a story to
themselves that's not really true little
fake right and they want to give
themselves an edge and then they chase
that thing with a kind of an actor but
they're not because they're not really
working on acting they're working on
going out and getting to know people and
they're [ __ ] the right people and it
just doesn't because they don't have to
have it they don't have to like I came
from we're talking about this off here I
went to the premiere of war dogs right
my buddy miles teller is it Todd Feldman
our mutual friend was there but your old
friends were there and I'm leaving after
there's an after party I was there for
maybe 30 minutes I stuffed my face with
this prime rib and roasted Brussels
sprouts and got out like a gentleman
with a diet coke guy got out like my
gentleman left the partying up to the
kids and when I got in my Oberer the
uber driver you know both talking he's
like ah yeah as a movie premiere Brown
the cat and he's older for sure he turns
around he goes you recognize me excuse
me is he recognized like no I
Oboro all the time I don't remember face
he's like no man I was in I for you some
old like blades of glory the original
one in 1970 bum like ya know like for
sure and I by the way and then he goes
that's right now and then hey and then
he goes I was an actor man same thing
I'm like oh yeah and I was like [ __ ] how
far does this ride get here
I was only literally three box but he
got his entire life story and yeah and
he's like the problem is is just you
know the schedule the odd dish I was at
the problem dish that and then you know
and then I had to pay rent and I go
that's a biggie man you got to do that
he's again you know and then he goes
leave this I'm like well okay and get
this phone out it's a selfie of him and
semester Salone depressed and I was
thought it was gonna be them on set nope
he gave semesters well on a ride before
he gave me a ride there
so many ways Donald Trump the one thing
I'll say about that guys he's so good at
just takin your wheels off was Marco
Rubio is just a little Marco over here
he's trying to get trying to be big it's
not working but I appreciate he's a dude
I've been wondering he's a boys boy if
you're not gonna yell and match Donald
Trump you're gonna be in trouble yeah
that's a good [ __ ] talker hey Ruby Larry
entertained guys day in attaining hey
look at Marco and this guy sweats he
sweats oh my hands how is he gonna be
he's got these tiny honey be in front of
you what your president with tiny hands
I didn't think about it but not really
you know I'm not really no no no you
mention it yeah I'm kind of worried
about his hands I literally was I was
like you got baby hands can't have that
bro
so a Brazilian federal judge issued an
order to like to take seized his
passport he's Aragon Massport yep he's
getting on there's one story but there's
one left though because he wants to
seize the four guys that were lying
three of them are gone there's one
dumbass left put the screws to him yeah
I'm hot Brazilian interrogation rooms
yeah the homies gonna run a Portuguese
training on it might just run a
Portuguese strain on them gets hot in
them and them interrogation runs oh we
don't foger the Chow on that ass
yeah we gonna clean up gonna clean the
floor with your face we're gonna forget
her Chaddock we're gonna IE all of your
face
we're gonna focus how you my dick I say
he yeah he's [ __ ] man good luck
repairing her image when you lie like
what was the point of like what do you
they say he was like at some shady party
and he was lying made the story up for
his because he has a wife or girl is
what people think like it was a you know
a big story but a little more hmm I'm
not because though I'm not because he
went on like you know good good more in
America some [ __ ] like yeah man yeah
kind of bravado about it kinda try to
make him seem like a badass
no no [ __ ] up we've got the only
fighter I know who's got two nicknames
Randy the natural Couture and Captain
America I call them the legend yes very
few guys I called legs you just gave him
a third we all call him a legend oh uh
you all other fighters to do it is a big
deal you've always had it been the
underdog I think that's why so many it
helped you in your career and it was
always like I don't know how Randy's
gonna pull this off yeah I seem to
operate well in that space and and I
think being I didn't start fighting
until I was 34 I think that
automatically at that age in a combative
sport puts you in that kind of an
underdog spot hundred percent and I
don't know if there's something about
being in that space where there's no
expectation you know that you could
you're free to just go out and do
whatever you do and not deal with the
pressure and you know being that guy
that's the number one that everybody
expects you to win and all that a lot of
guys don't deal with that well and I
actually struggle with that too and on
occasion I mean really the two Olympics
I was supposed to make the team in 92
and 96 I was the number one guy I was
the guy everybody thought was gonna make
the team and win the medal and I managed
to come up short both those occasions do
you have did you have trouble because of
your and the intensity of your training
and how intense your fight career was
and then of course you've gone to movies
and you've had you've been one of those
guys that just stayed so relevant but it
is a different mentality it's a
different lifestyle now was it hard for
you to make that adjustment
yeah one of the first things I needed to
adjust I realized was my eating habits
the training twice a day five six days a
week you can get away with a lot you can
eat that banana split no he eat a lot of
food we had to especially as a
heavyweight or a small heavyweight and I
thought man I gotta do something
different or I'm gonna be a fat pig if a
guy who I definitely had to make an
adjustment there wasn't burn in those
kind of calories anymore and
and then you know wanting to slow down
smell the roses enjoy life a little bit
after 14 years of is that it's it's not
easy and I still find myself at times
like man I'm busier than I've ever been
and like you know well let's take a week
off let's go ride a motorcycle for a
week or do something
do you wanna force myself to force
yourself do you find movies to be as
boring as I do they it is a grind I once
was in a dish I once was in a discussion
with a UFC official I won't name and he
goes we will bury you like Randy Couture
Randy's killing it huge movie wait are
you sitting off we're all expendable sir
I'll take now just gonna keep talking
chair I'll take it yeah I started
laughing man yeah that was the threat
will bury you like we did Randy we can
bury Randy Couture you don't think you
know we could nah I just saw him on a
preview for a huge move is that what
we're talking about here are you my
agent
yes Punk'd why was I fighting why did I
jump into fighting and try fighting man
cuz it list looks like a blast we talked
about this all time you can get caught
up in this as the podcast grows you can
start thinking or whatever you do you
can start thinking about the money or
starting thinking about growing this
thing you got to keep it fun you got to
come back to the fun this is why we do
what we do and and yeah we're wired a
particular way I'm gonna put my best
foot forward give it everything I got
and never gonna quit I'm gonna learn and
try to tweak and get better each and
every time I step out there that's just
how we're wired that's what we do but it
sure as hell better be fun why else
would you want to do it that's so
important it has do you still have a
relationship with the guys like Chuck
Liddell T Delancey Chuck every now and
then I see Tito a lot more especially
now because he's like with Bellator and
I'm getting to be a brand ambassador in
there for Bellator some of their events
that's been fun I've done a couple of
charity things with Tito it's been fun
he calls me Dad does he really yeah
in Nashville and somebody came up doses
like hey is that your dad so every time
he sees me they bad how's it going I
said don't make me spank you again one
more fight with someone from any weight
class who would it have been and where
uh I mean obviously the only fight that
I felt like I chased for a while that
didn't happen was was the fatal evade or
yes especially when we were both the
only we were ranked one and two in the
world he was with pride I was with the
you see when they leaked the post tried
to yes affliction did that there was
some intention there it was that it sits
there was the dream fighter everyone
yeah they'll eat this poster was like oh
even now today you know and Fedor's had
his ups and downs but anybody that
fights that guy I mean there's gonna be
a highlight reel yeah whether he's on
one end of it or you're on one end of it
everybody's gonna watch to see what
happens fight I did Maldonado yeah rough
I was a yeah it was a brawl a lot of
people thought he lost that fight no
they did yeah Randy what is your
favorite Evan Tanner story or just any
good story from the old quest days oh
man a Vinci Anna was such an interesting
guy and it came and stayed with me for a
couple of weeks he wasn't comfortable
being in my house he felt like he was
putting me out and I care one way or the
other but every time I saw of any he was
part of this book club with his
leather-bound you know gold gold bound
books awesome reading Moby Dick reading
I mean all these classic books it was
like an elastic book club so he always
had one of those books with him
everywhere he went he finally decided he
just wasn't comfortable staying in a
room in my house so they got his stuff
squared away he went and stayed in a
trailer out behind Team Quest out behind
the used-car lot that was a quest no
water no showers nothing there training
you know coming into Jimin and the guy
that Joel that that owned the car
dealership with Matt loved it because he
was having trouble people breaking into
that bat lot now he had a built-in
bodyguard for security guard there all
the time
come in in the morning and we had this
couch and Evan sitting on the couch and
he can't even open his eyes and I'm like
dude did you sleep what happened what
are you alright
he said yeah I just had left my contacts
in for this whole last weekend when I
took him on a I think he hadn't washed
his contacts or anything and he peeled
it really like damaged his eyes that I'm
like are you kidding me
I mean I got a washing machine I got a
shower I got man and that was just Evan
though classic March to his own drum I
was just thinking about how far we've
come to this podcast and Randy Couture
is a guest it's kind of it's kind of
cool for break tour up in there the
Bellator next thank you guys
it's next X right the 26 Honda Center oh
yeah